hey remember how Trump tweeted that
Obama wiretap Trump Tower during the
election well according to FBI director
James Comey there's no evidence for that
and other obvious internet news you
totally cannot ask three HS to your car
even if you could there are zero horny
milfs in your area all right FBI
director and national spoil sport James
Comey testified to Congress today about
Trump's claim saying I have no
information that supports those tweets
yes we're at the point where the
director of a federal law enforcement
agency has to take time out of his work
to talk about tweet yeah I don't know if
I remember Jandra Hoover having to deal
with Grindr all right bad example that
is a bad example in the bad example a
comedian yeah I actually do remember him
you're doing really good okay
great you actually did a long night
I'm obviously gay what are we talking
about what's something else you could
tweet to prompt that responsive FBI
director James Comey dumb women marry me
for my giant hands and my tolerance of
them coming from any country on the
planet no information that supports
those tweets yeah Dana I have the most
diverse cabinet ever we have every shade
from tasty to bloated corpse I have no
information that supports those tweets
tail Kellyanne Conway is not a waterfall
with eyes I have no information that
supports those trees
[Applause]